we're going to begin this hour with a
new project from comedian and actress
Sebastian Maniscalco if you've seen any
of his any of his stand-up routines you
know he is laugh out loud hilarious pee
in your pants funny yeah you also know
he spends a lot of time talking about
his wife and his kids
why is everybody bragging about their
kids don't we have any
my parents were honest with people they
never bragged about me
foreign
as soon as we walked in my father was
like yeah we don't know what the hell's
wrong with him
oh God he cracks me it's funny because
it's true you're right Nate Sebastian's
the father of a five-year-old daughter
her name is Seraphina she's a cutie and
three-year-old Caruso also cute now he's
teaming up with pediatrician Dr Scott
Cohen the author of Eat Sleep poop like
that title they've launched a parenting
podcast listen to this it's called daddy
versus doctor they share advice and
their own parenting Adventures here's a
look
good morning everybody my name is
Sebastian Maniscalco I'm sitting here
with Dr Scott Cohen who is our
pediatrician now we are joined by a
beautiful couple here gando and Malika
and they have a kid 13 months old arav
who's dealing with tempered Tantrums now
we're going to see what's going on in
their world take a look at this clip
he's full of energy
when he's happy he is happy he is
excited he is bouncing around everywhere
he's amazing and he smiles race being
almost in tears because it's just
awesome it's such a great feeling
[Music]
well the Tantrums really make me feel
helpless in a way what's wrong with him
am I doing something wrong am I missing
something
but his Tantrums are passionate if
something is not going right he will let
you know he's very very emotional when
it comes to that he'll throw things
you might feel mom guilt you know like
why can I not figure this out he knows
what he wants and so he's driven that's
what I love about him I didn't grow up
with the father so it's been hard
because I still know what I'm doing
sometimes I want to do it right
wow now watching that video for me
brought back memories should they be
worried is this normal behavior I mean
first of all which side of the family
does this Behavior take after
maybe both yeah this is so common
happened with you or two it happened
with my two girls and there's not one
size fits all when it comes to Parenting
like what did you do when when Caruso
was flipping out on the floor I called
my wife
what I would do is I would change the
environment that the kid was in so it
was in the living room I'd pick him up
I'd bring them to the garage or whatever
change the environment see I got you
distraction works really well it works
well for Sebastian's Behavior sometimes
something simple knocking on a door
Clapping Your Hands waving you gotta try
different things at different times I
saw the head bang and my son was doing
that uh for a little bit is that
something where you put like a pillow
between the wall and the head because
once I saw that I'm like that's it you
know I I always look at it as as a major
issue whatever they have like like you
just said my kid's the only one doing
this something's wrong our DNA is
screwed up you know that behavior is
attention-seeking behavior so like you
said you want to make sure he's in a
safe place right he's not on a cement
floor you want to move him over to
carpet or something but in reality if
he's head banging you can let it be he
really won't hurt himself and now you
just have the ability to ignore this
what do you do in your head to just kind
of yeah forget about it I mean either
I'll just tune it out or put the TV on
watch something and then she'll be like
he's been crying this whole time and I'm
like oh I don't know what uh what to do
so I just kind of go to the other rooms
sometimes and look at the baby monitor
and like hope he's okay you know parents
are the ones who need the timeout
sometimes yeah right like you need to
just take a deep breath go in another
room settle and then you can come at it
in a different way yeah the idea is sort
of of as he gets older ignore behaviors
you want to get rid of give attention to
ones you want to keep
when Tantrums happen it can cause other
emotions between us and all of a sudden
you know more me
but then but like it's you know you know
what I mean like the in the arguments
start to happen and then we're like why
are we all young
why are we we don't hate each other like
what's going on here how does one handle
all of that when everything's going
wrong if you will you know marital
advice right off the bat yeah yeah this
happens all the time in my house it's
the kid and then you know the soup is
third and the motion start there's an
argument it's difficult to manage that
now you have a wonderful wonderful
marriage and and you guys never argue
how do you do it right
um your wife is always right you know
that rule I just learned that we've been
together for over 20 years so I just the
parents taking a time out taking a deep
breath sometimes de-escalating can be
helpful yay
there we go you can parent different
ways dad's comparing differently than
moms and that's totally normal and
they're both right and I think keeping
the relationship scheduling date nights
doing things outside the parenting world
so that you feel that you're in your
relationship too to have these moments
where you guys could connect as a couple
definitely help uh so Friday nights we
just go to his house so if you guys want
to come over no kids and that just the
kids are going to be okay it's hard to
mess them up I mean look you had two
kids
if I could do it anybody that's it I say
the same thing
hello Sebastian Maniscalco and Dr Scott
Cohen you just said Sebastian if I can
do it anybody can do it but I think it's
I want people to hear how the two of you
got together because I assume Sebastian
it was your idea but Dr Cohen says Nope
yep it was his idea hold that hold that
thought Sebastian because your idea Dr
Cohen I know don't seem so surprised
coming up we'll talk with them about
their new podcast and how they hope to
help parents parents that's you around
the country